[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Hello, my name's
Yukio Lippit and I'm
the faculty director of the
Arts at the Radcliffe Institute.
And I'd like to extend a
warm welcome to all of you
to this very special event,
the opening and celebration
of our exhibition of the
artist Matika Wilbur, titled
Seeds of Culture:
Portraits and Stories
of Native American Women at
Radcliffe's Johnson-Kulukundis
Family gallery.
Now we have a wonderful
program, which
includes special
musical performances,
and we'll be hearing from
Matika Wilbur herself.
But first, we would like to
acknowledge the Massachusetts
Nipmuc and Wampanoag
tribes, whose land we
are on this evening.
And begin with the blessing
by Mary Anne Hendricks,
who is Sachem or paramount
chief, of the Natick Nipmuc.
-Hello.
[NON-ENGLISH] Oh, my
dear creator, hear me.
I want to acknowledge the
Radcliffe Institute and Harvard
University Native
American Program
for the interest they've
shown in attempting
to end the exploitation
of indigenous persons.
I also want to bless the
many tribes represented here
tonight, and the first people
on whose land we stand.
Too often we have been
faced with ignorance.
For example, referring
to our regalia
as costumes, used in culturally
inappropriate and derogatory
term, team names,
and statesmanship
we no longer exist.
Well to quote one of our
native Nipmuc scholars,
Kristen Wyman she said,
"For hundreds of years,
our people have been
used and exploited
in the colonizer's pursuit
of greed and power.
Using our identity
for any means,
without validating our existence
is contradictory in nature,
and only spreads the
seeds of ignorance.
If one truly supports--" I think
I'm a little stiff at this age.
"If one truly supports
bringing our culture to life,
one will allow that culture
to speak for itself.
Matika Wilbur, Native American
photographer and documentarian,
is doing just that, allowing
culture to speak for itself.
She is spreading the seeds
of truth and knowledge.
Please bless Matika Wilbur
on her journey, and may
society learned
from her endeavors."
-Thank you very much,
Mary Anne Hendricks.
By way of introducing today's
featured artist, Matika
and performers, I'd like to
note that this exhibition marks
a culminating moment of two
aspects of the Radcliffe
Institute.
And the first is our
research theme for the year,
in partnership with HUNAP,
Harvard University Native
American Program, which is the
study of indigenous peoples
and will be marked
by our conference
tomorrow in this very
gym, titled Native Peoples
Native Politics, which
begins at 9:00 AM.
And actually,
there is a postcard
of the event on
seats for all of you,
which will also feature
Matika as a participant,
as well as many other
distinguished speakers.
The second aspect is that
this is the culmination
of a heady first
year in the life
of our new gallery
at Radcliffe, which
opened only this past October.
And because our arts program in
the academic ventures division
strives to champion the
arts as really a unique way
of understanding the world
in forms that are not always
foregrounded in other
ways of knowing,
through particular
forms of experimentation
and innovation, the senses,
memory, intimate experience
and empathy.
We feel that we found
the ideal artist
with whom to work in Matika.
Matika Wilbur is a critically
acclaimed photographer, writer,
and social documentarian.
She's a member of the
Swinomish and Tulalip tribes
of the state of
Washington, where
she was raised in a family
of commercial fisherman.
I'd like to extend a warm
welcome to her mother
Nancy, and nephew Treyton who
are with us in the audience
today.
[APPLAUSE]
Matika went on to
study photography
at the Brooks
Institute in California
and the Rocky Mountain School
of Photography in Montana.
Over 10 years ago, she began to
develop a monumental aspiration
that has led to her work today.
To help develop
a body of imagery
in cultural representations
of native peoples
to counteract the relentlessly
insipid one dimensional
stereotypes circulating
in mainstream media,
historical textbooks,
and the culture industry.
To create, in her own words,
positive indigenous role
models, to do justice to
the richness and diversity
and lived experiences
of Indian country.
In 2012, she sold everything
in her Seattle apartment
and created Project 562,
which reflects her commitment
to visit, engage and
photograph all 562
plus Native American sovereign
territories in the United
States.
This project has driven her to
travel hundreds of thousands
of miles, many in
her RV, The Big Girl.
But also by horseback
through the Grand Canyon,
by train, plane, and boat.
By foot across
all 50 states, she
reflects a remarkable
way of being an artist
in the contemporary world.
Kickstarter-funded with a large
community of online supporters,
sleeping on sofas,
she is welcomed
and hosted by strangers who
soon become friends, and share
the aspirations of the
artist in her project.
The photographs that
Matika takes reflect
her consummate craftsmanship,
beautiful black and white
images that selectively
incorporate color,
and showcase are subjects
in vital mutualism
with the lands on which they
live, in which they steward.
But her virtuoso technique
is only one aspect
of the social and cultural
meaning of the works.
They are one product of
her dynamic engagement
with native communities,
in which she takes the time
to understand the stories and
histories of particular tribes,
each particular tribe, each
individual, and experience
what shapes entirely the way
the portrait comes to be.
One gets the sense that these
works reflect true partnerships
between artist and sitter.
The photographs
that you will see
in the gallery or but a
small but truly remarkable
sample of her work.
Because Radcliffe is
an institution that
has historically been dedicated
to the education of women,
we were moved and delighted
when Matika proposed
to curate a show
for us, focusing
on Native American women,
the women of Project 562.
What you witness in the
gallery through the selection
is wide ranging diversity and
richness of the identities
and experiences, the stories
of Native American women.
You will encounter teachers,
daughters, linguists,
activists, artists, mothers,
PhDs, elders, professionals,
grandmothers, Ivy
League students,
and community organizers.
They are accompanied
by a booklet that
convey the words and stories
of these individuals,
and also an audio track that
fills the room with songs,
prayers, and the texture
and timber of the voices
of these individuals.
Collectively, these
representations
convey intimate experience,
but also epic tradition.
The entire range of human
emotions is represented.
The sadness and trauma of
genocide, colonization,
but also an abundance of hope,
determination, joy, and humor,
and complexity.
The resourcefulness
and strategies
by which these women
negotiate identity
and their multiple points
of cultural reference
in the contemporary world.
These stories are all framed
against very different
landscapes, the landscapes of
the 562, desert, valley, river,
ocean, mountains,
coast, snow scape.
Indeed, in the
gallery, Matika's work
has managed to create
its own cosmology
of the many different
regions and narratives
of native communities
everywhere.
All of us who have worked on
the exhibition at the Radcliffe
Institute, including the
members of the Academic Ventures
division, our colleagues
in events, communications,
facilities, the Fellows
office, the Dean's office,
as well as our
friends and partners
and collaborators at HUNAP,
directed by Shelly Lowe,
would like to convey
heartfelt thanks to Matika,
who had given as tireless
energy, will, artistry
and enthusiasm to this project.
We'd like to thank our
exhibition advisor, Adrienne
Keene and members of team 562.
And also we would like
to thank the women
in the portraits in the
gallery for allowing
us to play a small role in
helping to tell their stories,
and to reimagine the
richness of Indian country.
Let me briefly describe
how this hour will proceed.
I'd like to introduce next,
our two guest performers
before asking Matika herself
to come to the podium
to address this audience.
After this presentation,
we will invite all of you
across the yard to the gallery.
We look forward to welcoming
you for a reception accompanying
the opening.
Now, our first performer
is Leah Shenandoah,
who is a Oneida Wolf clan member
of the Iroquois Confederacy.
She comes from a lineage
of distinguished artists
and musicians, and her work
with her mother, Grammy Award
winning Joanne Shenandoah, has
gained international acclaim.
She has won numerous
awards, including
debut artist of the year in 2014
by the Native American Music
Awards, and best
alternative recording.
She's performed
all over the world,
including at the
Vatican, the White House,
and before His Holiness,
the Dalai Lama.
We are privileged
to be next in line
at the Radcliffe Institute.
Please join me in
welcoming Leah Shenandoah.
-So, I'm Leah Shenandoah.
My native name is Kaha whi'tha,
which means she carries along.
And I will sing the song
we sang at the Vatican,
and in front of His
Holiness the Dalai Lama.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
So the next one
I'm going to sing
is not an album or
anything, so bear with me.
It's called Frankenhearted.
[SINGING] Early morning bird
song exalting sunrise, sunrise.
Heartbeat pounding, my little
breath filled with wonder,
do you lie awake too?
Do on your cheek, heavens and
hell, tucked beneath your feet?
I loved you once,
I can't try again.
But I am happy,
yeah, for resting,
I am reborn every morning.
Lovers embrace, a
ghostly remembrance.
Not even a trace,
my fiery ache leaves
me frakenhearted, but
stronger than before.
So I bless your sorrows, empty
promises, and better tomorrows.
I loved you once
as the raven cries
and interruption
of my beauty sleep.
[APPLAUSE]
That one's not recorded.
The third one is off
my Nammy winning album,
which is called
Weight of the World.
This is about my
progression, finding self
love, which I think is one
of the most difficult things
to do in this day and age.
[SINGING] Weight of the
world, put a curve in my neck.
I shuddered from
years of disrespect.
Recently, I discovered
my true self,
hidden behind years of neglect.
I am my higher self.
I am full of sunsets.
Light shine bright,
beautiful, and correct.
My feet, no they don't waver.
My path is in step.
Dancing in the moonlight,
my energy connects all.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I go.
I have to say happy
birthday Matika.
I had to do it.
You're the best.
Thank you so much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you very much, Leah.
Our next performer, Laura
Ortman is White Mountain Apache,
and is a Brooklyn based
composer, musician,
and visual artist.
Based on her expertise in a wide
range of musical instruments,
but most notably, violin,
electric guitar, and vocals,
she's formed a number
of musical groups
that are performed around
the world, including
Dust Dive from 2000 onward,
National Braid from 2001
onward, and The Coast Orchestra,
and All Native American
Orchestral ensemble in 2008.
This year, she'll release
her third solo album, My Soul
Remainer.
She will perform
original songs that
are inspired by
Matika's show, and she
says, "The presence of everyone
who has come to see it,
all of you, all of us."
Please join me in
welcoming Laura Ortman
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you.
As made both implicit
and explicit,
there are two performers,
somehow by fortuitous aligning
of the stars, the opening
for this exhibition
has coincided with the
featured artist's birthday.
So without futher-- this
is a celebratory occasion,
in many sense.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming to the
stage Matika Wilbur.
[APPLAUSE]
-Wow!
Oh, my gosh, wow.
How wonderful that
all of you are here.
Thank you for being here.
Let me say-- wow, Leah
and Laura, thank you.
[NON-ENGLISH] Wow.
And hello, friends
and relatives.
My name is Matika Wilbur.
I'm from the Swinomish
and Tulalip tribe.
And my mom is Nancy Wilbur.
My maternal grandmother,
Laura Wilbur.
My father, Kenny Joseph.
My paternal grandmother,
Loretta James.
Gosh, it is just such a
pleasure to be here with each
and every one of you today.
And I just really
want to thank you
so much for taking the
time out of your busy lives
to come here tonight, it
really means so much to me.
So, from my heart
to yours, thank you.
I'd like to offer a big
warm honey thank you
to the elders here
with us this evening,
and to the Massachusetts
Wampanoag and Nitmuc people.
[NON-ENGLISH] Thank you for
allowing us to be within
your indigenous territory.
And let me preface
that also by saying
I appreciate your wisdom
and your knowledge,
my sweet elders.
And I appreciate you letting
me share with you tonight.
I'd like to share messages
that have been entrusted
to me on the road,
and some of the hard
earned discoveries
from the road.
So for the past
three years, I've
been on this adventurous
sojourn into Indian country.
I set off with the intention to
photograph every one of tribes
in the United States, 562
federally recognized tribes
at its inception.
Why?
To change the way we
see native America.
In that time, I've realized
that the best way to see,
is first to listen.
And what have I
listened to mostly
for the last several years?
Indigenous stories of
every imaginable variety.
The stories from Turtle Island.
And I want to tell you the
story of Turtle Island,
it's one of my favorites.
And it goes a little
something like this.
And it should be
said that this is
shared by so many communities
across Turtle Island.
So, you might have heard
a different version
of this story, and if you want
to argue about it afterwards,
I'm down with that.
So long, long ago,
when the world was new
and there was no
land, only water,
powerful beings lived in a
place called the sky world.
One day, a curious,
young, expecting woman
dug a hole at the base
of the tree of life,
until she could see through
to the other side below.
And you know, she's curious.
She can't help but
peek through the hole.
And suddenly, she
starts to slip.
And she starts reaching
and grabbing for everything
that she can find, and she
gets herself some dirt,
and she grabs a few seeds, and
she begins to fall, and fall,
and tumble into the vastness.
She's spinning and
turning and floating
through the expanse, past the
moon, towards the blue dot.
And all of the animals
below, the winged beings
and sea creatures,
they see her falling.
And they say the to each
other, if we don't help her,
she's going to
make a huge splash,
and that is going
to ruin our day.
And so, they decide to save her.
So the birds, they fly up
above, and they catch her,
and they soften her fall.
And they place her on the
back of a giant turtle.
Sky Woman gives
birth to two babies,
and from those seeds,
earth and babies,
the world is formed
and dance into being
and became the Turtle Island
that we walk upon right now.
I have another story for you.
A long time ago, there
was only darkness.
A man, god created,
the heaven and earth.
And the earth was
without form, and void,
and darkness was upon
the face of deep.
And the spirit of God moved
upon the face of the waters,
and God said, "Let there be
light," and there was light.
God created night and
day, the sun and the moon,
and all the creatures
of the world.
And finally, he creates human,
man first, and then a woman.
Adam and Eve.
And he places
everything and everyone
into one garden,
a perfect world,
where there's no sickness,
no death, no hate, no hunger.
There's only one rule, and
you know the rest of story.
One of my favorite
authors, Thomas King,
he wrote a book called
The Truth about Stories:
A Native Narrative.
He starts with the big
picture, a comparison
of this indigenous
creation story,
like the one I just told
you, in the book of Genesis
of Judeo Christian traditions.
The story of Sky Woman
introduces the talking animals
almost straight away,
which is, as King
says, a bit of a problem.
The chatty fish and
friendly rabbits
of indigenous literature allow
people to label [? ablet ?]
as simplistic, and indigenous
societies as primitive.
But as King shows,
the talking animals
are actually quite
sophisticated.
They speak of a
world where balance
is the norm, where the
world is shared, where chaos
is turned into an organization.
Compare that with Judeo
Christian worldviews, where
in Genesis, hierarchy,
individualism, and organization
degenerate into chaos,
accompanied by aggression,
an enemy.
The Eden story is why
Western society favors order,
rationality, and
material constructs,
along with systems of
judgment, superiority, and male
domination.
The primary role of
traditional indigenous story,
on the other hand, was
creating and fostering
equality between
all living things.
At the heart of Sky
Woman's creation
story is the idea of
universal equality,
and importance of the
female essence and instinct,
stewardship, and knowledge.
It cherishes and
cultivates equality
between the males
and the females,
and especially the roles,
and all of creation.
As it happens, so
many of the stories
I've been given
in my journey also
originate from and
relate to native women.
I understand that
these stories are
fundamental to how we see
and understand the world
and ourselves.
As King says, the truth about
stories is that's all we are.
I have to tell you
though, the stories
that I've been hearing
from native women
all over the country
have lain heavily.
When I sit down to listen to our
people, especially our women,
they erupt with their
innermost stories.
For some reason,
they want me to know.
Maybe it's because
they understood
that you and I would be sitting
here together in this room
and I'd be sharing
stories with you,
and that maybe these
stories would someday
save somebody's life.
Or maybe, it is just because
desperately, somewhere,
we all yearn to be justified
by the telling of our truths.
And the stories that
I've heard are the kind
that are hard to repeat.
Grandmas tell me about what
happened to them in IHS
clinics, of how they've gone
in to have their first baby,
and were never able to
conceive again, only
to find out years later
that they'd been sterilized
without their consent.
Victims of a de facto
government, one child policy.
Married women tell me about
their abusive husbands,
of the violence, and
loneliness, and despair,
and their fear of leaving.
One lady told me about how
she was raped in the army,
then was demoted
when she saw justice.
Upon returning home with a
mixed race child born of rape,
she was made to feel like an
outcast in her own community.
Women talk about there
alarm about tribal children
committing suicide,
as many already have.
We talk about and sheds
tears for our elders
that are passing away, and
with their passing is also
the death of our
indigenous languages.
Aunties talk about the
plants that are dying,
the water not returning, and
creatures around them at risk.
Women tell me how
difficult it is
to choose a mate when
racist policies determine
their future
children's opportunity
for tribal citizenship.
And women speak with me about
the difficulty of fitting
into academic environments,
when the faces, books,
and spaces around them
do not include them.
Teachers express the ways
that teaching to the test
inhibits their ability
to teach the truths
about native America.
Single mothers
share their struggle
to find money to make rent.
It's a lot.
They tell me stories
about race, and caste,
and how their bodies are
used to perpetuate both.
High caste women are
sexually restricted,
while women at the bottom
are sexually exploited.
And while I wanted
to come here tonight
and share desperately with you,
stories of beauty and light
and love and nothing but
chuckle and happiness and joy,
because after all,
it's my birthday
and we're trying to celebrate.
I felt like I had to be a
little real with you tonight.
I have to tell you that
these experiences articulate
our current
socioeconomic situation.
Native American women are the
most victimized in the country.
Three out of four
have experienced
sexual assault or domestic
abuse in their lifetimes.
For most native women, it is not
the question of if, but when.
Across the border
in Canada, there
are an estimated 1,181
stolen sisters, women
from age 2 to 78,
disappeared and never found.
Missing, and likely murdered.
There's no question that we
are in a very critical time,
and a longstanding epidemic
of abuse and misuse
towards our native
women and children.
And these hard and
real stories are
connected to the compelling
native female narrative,
from Sky Woman
forward, and deserve
to be told as part of
the collective voice
of Indian women.
But who will tell them?
And how shall they be told?
In our exhibition,
Seeds of Culture:
The Portraits and Stories
of Native American Women,
native women are here to
tell you their own stories.
Native women
suffering and loss are
part of the indigenous
reality that exists,
that must be respected.
It must be of concern to us all.
I though have found, also
in our women's stories,
a treasure trove of knowledge,
strength, and vision.
You will meet, in
this exhibition, women
that endure the crisis and
transform the narrative, women
who prosper, who
become self actualized,
and fight for our nationhood.
Who carry our culture forward,
save our languages, seeds,
histories, and lives, while
birthing our next leaders
and putting to rest the
previous generation.
Women fully understanding the
complexities and power of story
as social shaping and crucial
to them and individual.
Women like this.
This is my girl [? Desi. ?]
She's great, you'd lover her.
She fierce.
She has that chuckle about
her that you just love.
She's infectious with
light and love and energy.
When you are around her, you
feel a little bit taller.
It's true.
And [? Desi ?] is a scholar.
She's currently
enrolled in a dual PhD
program with the
University of Arizona
and the University of
Waikato in New Zealand.
And after earning bachelor's and
master's degrees from Stanford,
she grew up on the northern
Cheyenne reservation.
She returned there after
her undergraduate studies,
and her academic path is shaped
and formed, and for her people.
She says, they call us
the fighting Cheyenne,
because we fought for everything
that we have here today.
I've grown up knowing
that we are here
because 300 of our people
made it back from Oklahoma.
They escaped in the
middle of winter
after being forced into
governmental Indian territory.
They were dying of
famine and disease,
and so to of our chiefs,
Dull Knife and Little Wolf,
decided that they were going
to make a run for freedom.
And if they died along
the way, at least
they died trying to get home.
So this really amazing tale of
survival of what a people would
do to be within their homeland.
Only 300 made it.
They were chased by the
cavalry the entire time,
in the middle of winter
for thousands of miles.
And for me, that's not
history, that's my reality.
That's a reality that our
people still live with.
It's not something that's
written down in history books,
it shapes your entire
life knowing every day
that your ancestors
died for you to be here.
And to me, that really
tells the strength
of the Cheyenne people.
One of the greatest truths
I've been given in my travels
is that Native American
lands is essential to
our Native American identity.
Where are the people of
the blue green water?
The people of the
tall pine trees?
The people that live within
the sacred mountains?
The people of the flowing tide?
But what happens when our
relationship with the land
is dramatically changed?
And although we
haven't relocated,
we feel displaced, because the
face of Mother Earth around us
has changed so dramatically.
Take for example what's
happening in Navajo Nation.
This is Dana Eldridge.
She's pictured during the
[NON-ENGLISH] meaning,
our journey for existence.
I know there's some
Navajos in here,
so I look at them like I
know I didn't say that right.
I'm sorry.
How many Navajos do we got here?
Come on.
Yeah, I knew it.
I'm just saying, Everywhere
I go in Indian country,
I run into lots of Navajos.
That's a good thing.
We like you here.
We're happy to be with you.
Welcome.
Please bring mutton.
Dana is in the
middle, in the midst.
When I took this
photo, we'd already
walked 40 miles that day.
They were walking 1,200 miles
on a pilgrimage across Navajo
Nations to all four
sacred mountains
to encourage the indigenous
uprising against fracking
and extraction from
the Mother Earth,
while returning to the sacred.
Americans recognize the
dangers and toxicity
of fracking in extracting
resources from Mother Earth.
Navajo people, such
as Dana, however,
feel the devastating
impacts firsthand.
I have to tell you, when
we were out walking,
there had been an
oil spill, and there
was people in full hazmat suits
cleaning up the oil spill not
even 10 yards away, where
little Indian babies were
playing on the playground.
It was so bad that
as we were walking,
we had to wear scarves
around our faces.
And yet, here are these children
playing in this environment.
If that was
happening right here,
or in downtown
Los Angeles, there
would be a major uprising.
And when I talked to
Dana, she explained
that 42% of Navajo
Nation is unemployed.
And the extractive
oil industries
promised jobs and other
financial incentives,
leaving people
with little choice
but to sign the
exploitative leases.
So here's the ladies.
They say they walk to honor the
resiliency of our ancestors,
who 150 years ago, were
forced to march hundreds
of miles in the dead of winter
on a genocidal death march.
They sacrificed and
suffered so much,
so that we could live within
these four sacred mountains.
And so we walk to honor
and remember them.
I think in what I've
found is that the way
that our land, the way
that we treat our land,
is directly related to the
way that we treat our women.
If we are willing to
penetrate the Earth
for her natural resources, I'm
afraid of the consequences.
Our women will also
feel its effects.
Oops.
Here we have a photo
of Miss Jenny Parker,
and her granddaughter
[? Charlease. ?]
And she's also from the
northern Cheyenne tribe.
And for 25 years,
she was a teacher
in the private Catholic
school on their reservation.
Until one day, when she
was teaching at the school,
and police came in uniform
and asked her to come
identify a body.
It was her daughter's.
She'd been assaulted,
sexually assaulted, and left.
And after that, Jenny
was just-- she just
said she was just kind
of a broken heart.
She had a heart attack.
She said, she just didn't think
she would be able to go on.
And then her granddaughter came
to her, and she said grandma,
I'm going to take care of you.
I'm going to move in with you.
And little by little,
they would walk
to the end of the
living room, and then
driveway, and then
to the end of the cul de sac.
And slowly, little by
little, she began healing.
And she says it's the
love, it's the love
between our grandchildren and
our families that heal us.
This is Deborah Parker
and her daughter, Carla.
Yeah.
And Deborah's from my
tribe, the Tulalip tribe.
She's awesome.
I don't know how to say it.
I mean, when i was teaching in
a tribal school for five years,
every Friday Deb came
and played with the kids.
And that kind of
leadership to me,
just-- she didn't
even have to talk
about the kind of
leadership it was,
she showed up all the time.
And she's a major
advocate, and has
advocated on behalf
of native women
during the fight to reauthorize
the Violence Against Women
Act, which was
held up in Congress
due to specific provisions
that would protect
native women and
tribal sovereignty.
She says of her work
on VOWA, "As a survivor
of domestic violence, I
knew that I would someday
be able to help another person.
I didn't really understand
the magnitude of the work
that I would be doing once
I became the vice chairwoman
of the Tulalip tribes.
I don't think anyone
could have seen it coming,
but I think my spirit new.
Because that flight to D.C. was
one of the most unique flights.
I was very quiet, and I knew
something was coming forward.
And when you are asked
to protect someone,
when you are asked
to protect a nation,
it's just what you have to do.
You armor up, you warrior
up, and you protect the women
in your nation.
It's a great honor to
do so, and all I can do
is pray that I'm
able to speak justice
toward the missing in
murdered indigenous women.
Every person deserves
to receive justice."
And you know something
incredible has recently
happened?
Deborah has advocated for
our tribal court system
to switch over to a
restorative justice system.
We will no longer be
imprisoning our people,
we will only be working
towards rehabbing our people.
And it's because
of women like this
that we're able to see
major change in communities.
How are you guys doing?
You doing all
right, you with me?
Damn, I know this is heavy.
It was hard for me, too.
Take a deep breath.
You can laugh if you want.
I'm just kidding, don't
laugh, it's not funny.
This is Doctor Mary
Evelyn Belgarde.
She's from the Pueblo of
Isleta in Okay Owinge.
She's a retired professor
of Indian education
from the University
of New Mexico.
She's collaborated
and establishing
several charters schools
focused on indigenous education.
She has raised funds to support
thousands of native students.
She is very passionate
about training
culturally competent
teachers to work
within indigenous communities.
She's well versed in the
history of boarding schools
and governmentally engineered
systems of education
and assimilation.
And during our
conversation, she asked
when are we going to stop
asking our children to choose
between cultural education
and Western education?
I think we're ready to stop
the assimilation process.
The time to change is right now.
This is Miss Helen.
I've never talked
about Miss Helen,
I just took this
photo three days ago.
And she's not in the show, but
I was so moved by my experience
when I met her, I had
to share it with you.
Miss Helen is 87 years old,
and miss Helen is blind
and she's only able to
hear out of one ear.
And I just came from
Nevada, I was visiting
all of the Piaute tribes.
And they all said to me, Matika,
you have to go meet Miss Helen.
And it's way out in the
desert, it's like four hours,
way out there, nothing but res.
I'm like, all right I'll go.
I didn't know why
I was going, I just
knew I was going
to meet Miss Helen.
And I show up there,
and I'm greeted
by Bird Man-- that's his name,
Bird Man-- and Miss Patty.
And they're the kind of folks
that greet you in the driveway.
They come out and they wave and
they show you where to park,
and they immediately
feed you, and then
they start telling
me their story.
Bird and Patty met
on this spirit walk,
and they fell in love, and then
Miss Patty contracted cancer,
and decided that
she wasn't going
to pursue Western
methodology of treatment,
and decided that she
needed to move home.
And when they got
home, there's only
in Lovelock Paiute there's
only 300 tribal members.
There's about 30 homes
there, and miss Helen
is the last Piaute language
speaker of their community.
And they brought me
over to meet her,
and they said-- so I sat
down with her and I said,
Miss Helen, I want
to take your picture.
She goes, ah, what do
you want to take-- you
don't want to take my picture.
I don't even look good.
Find some young, cute girl.
And I said, well,
Miss Helen, I've
been sent by all the
Piatues to meet you,
because I understand that you're
the last language speaker.
And miss Helen started crying.
And she's like, it's true,
I am the last person here
I have left to talk to.
And then, Bird and Patty
brought over these little kids,
like these seven
and eight-year-olds
who they had been teaching
songs to sing to Miss Helen.
And man, I gotta tell you--
I was driving away from them
my way to come here.
And I just had to
pull over and cry
for a little bit in the desert.
Imagine losing an
entire language.
That's where we're at right now.
That's happening all
over Indian country.
And that's why it's
a great privilege
to be here with you smart kids
and you smart folks tonight,
because we're the
type of folks that
can do something about that.
And that's powerful and
profound, and moving.
And that's why I
feel honored to get
to take pictures of
people like Miss Helen,
and share their story with you.
This is Miss Jo Re
[? Lefrends, ?] and
she's a student at Dartmouth.
And I took this
photo at Crow Fair.
Any of y'all been to Crow Fair?
I know you've been
to Crow Fair, Frank.
You know, Crow Fair is like
this rodeo and this pow-wow,
and there's like a
thousand teepees set up,
and I'd never stayed
in a teepee before.
Like I'm from Longhouse people,
we don't stay in teepees.
And I went out to Crow
Fair, and I'd never even
like-- I hadn't ever
rode a horse like this
and been in this kind of place.
Anyway, the point
is, when I met Jo Re,
I was amazed by her
strong commitment
to her culture to going home
every year to be a part of Crow
Fair, and to also
at the same time,
be this powerhouse student,
wavering through the experience
of being a young indigenous
person in a place that
doesn't mirror herself.
And I think it's worth
seeing in a place like this.
It might be time for us to
create fostering and nurturing
environments for our
Indian students to succeed.
This is what we know
50% of native students
drop out of high school.
10%, 5%?
5% go on to college.
10% of those students
graduate from college.
That's a major achievement gap.
So when we meet young
ladies like Miss Jo Re,
we have to acknowledge
how profound it
is that she is there, and thank
her for her incredible courage.
I'm almost done, Yukio.
I'm just kidding.
You guys still with me?
Yeah?
OK, good.
This is Miss Rowan White,
and she's a seed keeper.
Isn't that amazing?
She taught me one
of the greatest
lessons I've learned to date.
Honestly, I didn't
even take this picture.
This is another photographer
that took this picture.
Mr. Kristine.
And I met Rowan at
the Seed Conference,
and she was handing out all of
these indigenous seeds that she
had gathered and collected
from all over the country,
encouraging our native sisters
to return to the ancestral
position of holding seeds.
She tole me something
that totally blew my mind.
She said, you know what happens
Matika, when we grow food?
I really, like, I fish.
She says, when you plant
corn, and you go out
and you talk to that corn
every day, and you sing to it,
and you pollinate
it, and you water it,
you develop this
incredible relationship.
And then you're able to
feed it to your babies.
And what happens
when you harvest
it is you realize that
from that one seed
you planted, what you get
is 1,000 seeds in return.
We realize that the
earth is plentiful,
and there is always
enough to share.
There is always
enough to give away.
And when we participate in
the Western capitalist system,
we learn that
scarcity is the truth.
We learn that we
all need our own.
We need own house,
we need your own car,
we need our own families.
The earth is abundant.
And she told me, she said--
I'm going to read to you some
of her words.
She said, "I've been asked to
be a vessel for their stories.
I'm a Mohawk woman, who comes
from a long line of people
who have tended
to soil and seeds
with reverence and devotion.
And it is through
these relationships
with plants and seeds
that I'm finding my way
home to a deeper understanding
of the magic of being human.
It is my hope that through
our educational offerings
that the seeds of hope can come
alive in the hearts and minds
of people all over this earth.
The message of the seeds is the
embodiment of hope and healing.
They are saying, we are still
here, we are still vibrant,
we are interconnected, we
helped nourish each other."
I just think that's profound.
I don't mean to awkwardly
pause for you, and for you
all not to know what to do.
But to me, that's
incredibly powerful,
and it moves me every
time I think about it.
In pre-European matrilineal
land based native America,
this was self evident.
Women then were responsible
for managing food preparation
and distribution, along with
developing all children.
And with such,
critical roles were
naturally prized and respected.
And in their remarkable
knowledge and cultivation
of the earth, native
women realized
a compelling interior truth,
that the created world was
abundant, based on their
experience of the land's
plentiful potential
generosity and altruism
should be core human values.
Women advocated this truth
in their prominent standing
in the order of tribes, and set
an overwhelmingly humane tone,
and so much else.
In our tribes,
there was no thought
of women being less or
subject to mistreatment
because they were female.
It was with the
arrival of whites,
an alien model of resource
taking and control
of intentional profit
oriented scarcity took hold.
And along with other
unfathomable cultural
destruction, women's land based
practices, values, and status
were lost.
Native Americans entered
a horrifying systemic
displacement of estrangement
from the natural giving world.
King explains that stories
are wondrous things,
and they are dangerous.
It leaves us with the hope that
if we create better stories
and stopped believing
in dangerous stories,
we can create a better world.
Because the truth about stories
is that we get the world
we imagine.
And in that sense, we
get the world we deserve.
So thank you so much, my
friends and relatives,
for listening, as I
share about my encounters
with our mothers, our
sisters, our grandmothers,
our indigenous women.
Native female advocates
for tribal women
well understand and
emphasize that our plight
is a longstanding consequence
of the destruction
and disruption of our
inherently matrilineal cultures.
Our indigenous stories,
knowledge systems, and values,
deserve appropriate
representation
in cultivation in places such
as Radcliffe and Harvard.
Our women deserve the right
to express those stories,
their individualism,
and their bodies,
free of social fictions and the
dysfunction long imposed on us.
And for all of us in
our shared heritage,
there is a rich transference
of power and possibility
when we decide to
accept and learn
of the indigenous narrative
and identity of this land.
So [NON-ENGLISH]
thank you so much.
And before I end, I'd like
to do something that is super
traditional to where I'm from.
And I hope you'll
allow me that moment.
I'd like to ask-- The gallery
you're about to go into,
it was a labor of love.
And it took a lot of people
to put that labor of love
together.
And so, I'd like to thank those
people in the traditional way
of where I come
from, so I'd like
to ask Mr. Yukio, if you could
come on stage for a moment.
OK, come stand here, Yukio.
Now, where I'm from,
when somebody honors us,
we wrap them in this way.
And so, I say to you, Yukio,
thank you for all of your help,
and for putting up
with my crazy schedule,
and my phone calls
from the Grand Canyon.
[NON-ENGLISH]
[APPLAUSE]
Mrs. Cohen, would you join
us for a moment, please?
Now, where I come from, when we
go, from [? on a potlatch, ?]
and we go to the canoe
journey, and when
we go to a new place,
the first thing we do
is we thank the leaders
for them inviting us
and for them allowing us to be
on their indigenous territory.
And so, I thought, who is
the chief of Radcliffe?
And my mom said, Matika,
you have to thank the chief.
And we were like, hmm.
And so we decided that
that chief was you.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
That's a Louie Gong y'all.
That's kind of a big deal.
[APPLAUSE]
You're dealing with Indians
y'all, we're long winded.
So, Miss Adrienne Keene.
Dr. Adrienne Keene, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
When you go into the
gallery this evening,
what you will have
accompanying the images is
a collection of stories, some
of them I read to you tonight.
And the truth is, I'm a
photographer, I'm not a writer,
and Miss King is an
incredible writer.
And so she graciously helped
me write these stories
with her beautiful, inspiring
mind and intelligence,
and also put up with me,
trying to navigate places
like Harvard.
And for that, I feel incredibly
honored for her friendship,
and for her steadfast
dedication to Indian country.
She just became a
professor at Brown?
A professor, at Brown, in Ivy.
Yay, Adrienne!
[APPLAUSE]
I'm going to give her this
shawl that my mama gave to me
a few years ago on my birthday.
I thought it was appropriate.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
I'm sorry, but
we're not done yet.
Miss Becky, Meg, Paul, and Mark.
Could you please join us?
Mr. Mark Hunter.
No, Mark.
For Miss Becky, we
have brought from her
from our traditional territory,
a weaving of the baskets.
Some say it's used-- we
put it-- when I was young,
they told me we wear this
basket around our neck,
and it tells us whether
we're single or not.
If the basket lain empty,
you're looking for a husband.
So I would suggest that
you fill this basket.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
This was recently gifted
to me by the people
from the Lovelock Paiute tribe.
They told me to
think of the children
when I wore this necklace, and
they asked me and thanked me
for my work that we're doing
to advocate for children.
And so I pass it to
you, in that spirit
and I thank you for you work.
[APPLAUSE]
Hold on.
I'm sorry, y'all.
I know, where did it go?
Here it is.
For you, Ms. Meg, I
brought you some bling.
She's the gallery
director, curator, manager.
She was the one that was
willing to text message me,
and she's the one that
helped me hang everything.
And you see, it
takes a whole tribe
to make something
like this happen,
and so I think her in that way.
[APPLAUSE]
Everybody, this is
my Uncle Mark Hunter.
Say hello, Uncle Mark Hunter.
He was going to kill me
later for doing this,
but I have to tell you
that he's my guiding
force and my strength.
And he will call me in
the middle of the night
as I'm driving down
long roads, and he'll
negotiate my contract
because he's an attorney,
and he will help me.
And he helps me write,
and he sings me songs when
I can no longer drive anymore.
And I adopted at
him with fry bread
when I was just a wee child.
And I think it was probably
the smartest thing I ever did.
So, my mom had this
medallion beaded for him,
for Project 562,
and so we thank you,
oh Brown, for everything
you do for us.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, of course, and so--
I know that you're all
anxious to see the
work, and to stand up,
so I just want to
thank you one more
time for all of you coming out.
It's a real pleasure
and honor for me,
and I really want you to know
that I feel super blessed
by your presence this evening.
And I hope that you've
learned something in the way
that I've shared, and I hope
it's been useful for you.
And I'm very moved to
be here with you, so
thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]